all right Chris
so where'd you grow up where are you
from originally I'm originally from
Carson Carson California tell me about
your family growing up uh grew up in a
good a good household uh without a dad
but uh raised by my mom and grandparents
I was born 1981.
um
come from a working class family
grandparents retired they worked
my mother worked she passed away
a few years back
um
uh what was your childhood like Machado
upbringing was uh privileged
um
pretty much got what I wanted
um stayed out of trouble
for the most part just like any regular
teenager kid got in a typical stuff that
a teenager would get into
uh didn't go to jail as a teenager
um
it's pretty cool it was pretty cool I
grew up in front of the TV acting with
Betty bridges in her active school he
finished high school
uh yes it went to Sherman Oaks Center
Farm Rich studies
um
went to college
uh
uh kind of uh
how did how it was it was different once
I became an adult because I was able to
do what I really wanted to do and I
wanted to do everything that I wasn't
supposed to do
I was attracted to that stuff all the
bad stuff you know I joined the Gang Too
as a teenager
um
but I was still I was still a good kid
still going to school it was uh more of
a tribal thing you know belonging to
somewhere somewhere you know I can't
blame that on my father not being in the
home some people do I don't
it was a decision I made as as a as a
child
um and everything after that
was just decisions that I made good ones
and bad ones
you got in some trouble
yeah I didn't start getting into trouble
until I was an adult
um I was arrested for armed robbery saw
charges uh uh I married I married early
uh on massive violence
um repeatedly
um
just a slew of things what was it what
was the first
uh from armed robbery tell me about that
it was like a misunderstanding you know
um
me and a friend of mine
we was uh hanging out we was young you
know probably like 18 we was hanging out
and we ran into a fellow a fellow uh
blood gang member
and she was going in the store she was
waiting on the store asking people for
change so we can get one of those cigars
or black them out or something
and uh we look in the store he got a gun
out
he's robbing the store and I'm like whoa
so by the time we could leave the area
the police I came everywhere and
arrested US and uh
we sat in jail for a little bit and
before we get interviewed by the
detectives
I told my buddy from my neighborhood I
said hey uh
let's just tell the truth we don't know
this dude we don't know we don't we have
nothing to do with nothing we don't even
know what was going on so we stuck to
that story
and uh that was the truth yeah it was
the truth
and uh they just let us out you know
and uh it must get now we missed one of
our friends funerals
one of my close friends because we was
in jail and a lot of people was mad at
us it's like oh you didn't come to the
funeral you know they didn't really they
didn't they never talked to me asked me
what was really going on
but uh
yeah
that was the first one second one was
like
uh maybe maybe some domestic stuff
uh
possessions
um
assaults terrorist threats
just this is a gang of [__]
gang of [__] what's the attraction
to all that
trouble
it was more like being a vigilante just
being freelance just just doing what I
wanted you know
um
making some fast money some quick money
a lot of it
um the delayed gratification of going to
college and doing it that way just
didn't appeal to you well I was doing
when I was in college I was selling I
was selling drugs at college
you know and and
you know things happen with that too
um
it was just it was just a a image that
was painted like let's get it now
because you don't know if you're gonna
be here tomorrow
so let's just get it now you know
um you know when you're young you think
you think for the right now you don't
think for the future
you want it like right now you know the
things we know today if we knew him back
then we wouldn't want to make those
decisions oh do you know I'm 40 years
old now 40. yeah
you got involved in drugs too oh yeah
yeah drugs crept up on me man about
a little bit before my mom died it was
always messing around with him but I
wasn't
all the way into it like that
um
it just led up to it you know uh from
from marijuana
alcohol just abusing those things
to meth uh until I was abusing that
going out of my mind uh to crack cocaine
even now you know currently
and um that's it's just it's just new to
me
and um it's an Escape
you know uh
just abusing it
not really caring
um
where's the drug life taking you know
usually
sends people spiraling downward
oh yeah uh
the drug life took me sparring down or
my health my physical health
gotta walk with a cane uh why is that
broke my spine uh snap my leg in half I
had about 100 foot fall out of a hotel
room window how'd that happen under the
influence
being under influence you felt Which
floor the six sixth floor yeah hotel
window you fell out yeah the window was
broken
I was trying to pull it closed
and I fell out of it
and uh
yeah the rest is history you know broke
my spine in the lumbar
cracked my sink room would you hit the
concrete
sixth floor yeah you're lucky to be
alive oh yeah
oh yeah and uh
since then you know I was I was healing
up doing well
but I it just it just wasn't it wasn't
progression so being in the hospital
taking all the medications
and uh
uh the IV shots that was giving me you
know caused a relapse
you know for the pain so started with
Heroin
um I couldn't get that anymore so meth
is so easy obtainable
so I was doing that I was making me go
loopy
and then somebody said try this
and I'm like okay
so I'll start doing that and uh
you know the best is still yet to come
with me
um
just trying to get a way out now do you
have kids yes
yeah I got kids
where are they are they with their
mothers
yeah
and where are you staying now
man I'm here and there I'm all over I'm
in the streets I'm homeless
how long has that been going on since my
injury since my accident you know I
wasn't homeless before my accident I was
working had my own place
um
just thriving
and uh
you know this accident took me back to
where I didn't want to be
just kind of kept me there
was that was how long ago
it's February 2022.
so a little over a year yeah
what's your biggest regret in all this
uh having an accident having my accident
yeah coming back down here
and having my accident if I wouldn't
have came back down here it wouldn't
have happened or it might have probably
would have just happened somewhere else
but it's one of my regrets
if you hadn't played around with drugs
you probably wouldn't have come down
here
that part
if I wasn't messing around nothing this
would have happened
sometimes it takes stuff to happen for
some people to change
everything ain't for everybody
what do you want to do when you're done
in college
I was thinking about audio engineering I
was in college for audio engineering I
was a history major so I wanted to
either teach
or just do something in an audio field
whether it was television or music
what's your biggest fear right now
um dying without leaving my kids
anything
and living this lifestyle dying is a
possibility
it increases
possibility increases
you know when you when you an active
addiction you're around people that's an
active addiction
everybody's on different frequencies you
know and and different comprehension
levels and reasoning skills are
diminished
capacity is just reason and P is just
gone so you when you're around that 24 7
Things Can Happen
things can happen it can go terribly
wrong very quick
you think having a dead in your life
might have
helped you avoid some of these things oh
yeah I believe I believe my dad was in
my life
it would uh helped tremendously
but at the time from what I know is
he wasn't right himself
he is now but back then he wasn't sold
it just
been a blind leading the blind so to
speak
and uh
me I don't want to lead anybody not
until I can leave myself
so I just keep my mouth shut about a lot
of things you know what's it like
falling out of a sixth floor window
man you see how you just the first thing
I thought when I was falling I was like
well I'm about to die this is it I first
thought that came in my head
and I'm hitting the ground everything
was black and I've been down there for a
while bleeding out
and uh
what time it did it happen
uh
like the late evening
and I've been down there for a while
um
that I was catastrophic right there
injury right there that was
how has it affected you now you're
walking with a cane
this sucks man because I can't fend for
myself all the way
I can't I can't I can't do a lot of
things
and uh you know in Los Angeles you'll
always be put to the test when you're in
the streets it's gonna be somebody
that's gonna try to test you
so
I can't sit and play Houdini
but I got to be prepared and be ready
for whatever contourism
and it's difficult because I put me in a
situation where it's killer be killed
but you know I don't I don't live my my
life to to go out and hurt people
but I do got to protect myself
but in protecting myself I can end up in
prison or end up dead
so it's tough
you find yourself to be self-destructive
no no
what's your greatest strength do you
think
speaking
talking
um
but you go through emotionally
um especially after the accident
I wouldn't say I go through things
emotionally
I just learned how to stop thinking
about what's been lost
and what can be gained
um
try not to dwell on how I used to be and
I think about how I can be now
um
drugs is not the problem
drugs do what they're supposed to do
uh ruin lives get you high uh they do
all that
uh
I just I just focus on what can become
you know now you know as your fall
change your attitude about what you're
doing
because it sounds like you're still
using
yes
um
it changed me a little bit
you know it's assembled me to a certain
extent
I feel that I'm a lot more humble what
are you using currently I like all drugs
I like all of them
I like to use all of them
is that because of your self-worth you
think or is it just
you just start screwing around with
these drugs and it's just my accident I
was looking for something to kill the
pain
and drugs kill the pain to help you
escape where were you escaping from
the pain the trauma the body trauma the
mental
the PTSD it gives me you're saying
before the accident or after that after
that or after oh yeah
there's a lot of PTSD from that oh yeah
but you were playing around with drugs
even before then oh yeah I was I was but
I wasn't
I don't feel like I was solely dependent
on them back then it was just like they
were there they were there now it's like
man where they at
it's different now
Chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in all
this
just don't move too fast too soon
you kind of gotta sometimes play possum
with yourself
you know you just
kind of got to let things play out it
gonna play out and then bust a move
when you're moving too fast
you uh
you won't see everything like on a
motorcycle when you're driving to right
in it too fast you get that tunnel
vision
it's kind of how life can be
moving too fast especially being on the
exceptions of some
you missed you'll miss something you'll
miss something that you probably would
have needed
to learn or see or know or you miss
something you'll miss the mark
all right Chris thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome hope you continue to heal
and uh
get your ass out of this neighborhood
most definitely
thank you for having me man thank you